it's been just seven months since a
British school girl who joined Islamic
state was found alive in a Syrian
refugee camp Shamima Begum had a baby
just a few days old and a plea to the UK
government I didn't know what I was
getting into and I left my child since
then her baby son has died and her
British citizenship has been revoked
but her request remains I want to come
home the personnel at the Home Office
may have changed since then but the
message has not the new Home Secretary
making her position clear talking to the
Sun on Sunday pretty Patel said our job
is to keep our country safe we don't
need people who have done harm and left
our country to be part of a death cult
and to perpetuate that ideology we
cannot have people who would do us harm
allowed to enter our country and that
includes this woman Shamima Begum was
just 15 years old when she travelled to
Syria she claims her only role in
Islamic state was to make babies for
those close to her family she's been
failed by authorities and used as a
political pawn I think there's a lot of
grandstanding going on at the moment I
think individual Home Secretary's are
using sadly shamina Begum has there as
an opportunity for their political
careers she's been a very very foolish
individual but she was groomed she was
groomed and she was brainwashed over 900
British citizens joined the Islamic
state group while many have died others
have had children and now live in
refugee camps the government is
reportedly considering plans to
repatriate these children while they may
be innocent it's an issue that's divided
for cabinet in answer to our questions
about these plans the government simply
said that the safety and security of the
country is the number-one priority but
the issue strikes to the heart of how we
deal with those who have lived amongst
so-called Islamic state are they an
insurmountable security threat or are
they citizens deserving of a second
chance for many bringing children back
is not only humane but safer for the
country they should be raised here where
it's safe
where they're going to be free of
radicalization hopefully and then where
they can kind of
thrive and contribute to British society
and not stay over there and some camp
its quality conditions be a risk of
radicalization maybe even develop a
hatred towards us and be sent over here
in the future at some point Shamima
bagans family are fighting a legal case
to have her citizenship reinstated that
alone won't bring her back she'll be
sure to face many obstacles and major
opposition
Helen Ann Smith Sky News